Trascrizione: camilla bisesti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Dobbiamo sensibilizzare.
Dobbiamo informare.
Dobbiamo rendere consapevoli le persone
dell'imminenza della crisi climatica.
Dobbiamo, dobbiamo.
Quante volte abbiamo sentito
questo appello, "Dobbiamo".
Siamo cresciuti con il mito
della consapevolezza.
A scuola, poi al lavoro,
in famiglia, in amore,
dobbiamo essere consapevoli,
Anche l'ambientalismo ha fatto proprio
questo modello, la consapevolezza.
Persone capaci di decisione,
razionali, sempre sul pezzo.
Pochi, pochi che hanno capito
e che devono convincere i tanti
che ancora non hanno capito,
che devono convertire.
Usiamo proprio questa parola,
"conversione ecologica".
Conversione ecologica:
quanto siamo manzoniani?
Quanto abbiamo in mente
la notte dell'Innominato?
Ma è sempre una questione
di consapevolezza?
È sempre una questione di coscienza,
O questa volta la consapevolezza
non ci verrà in aiuto?
Forse non abbiamo più tempo,
forse non abbiamo più tempo
perché è il momento
di arrivare alle moltitudini.
Questa è la tesi:
non basta l'impegno consapevole di pochi,
abbiamo bisogno dell'azione
inconsapevole dei tutti.
Io ho detto azione,
non ho detto comprensione,
perché questo è il passaggio.
L'"homo sapiens", che è l'uomo che sa,
è l'uomo che ha coscienza,
è l'uomo che ha consapevolezza,
non è "Homo agens", l'uomo che sa agire.
È il 1903. John Miur, in America,
è già il naturalista e filosofo
più accreditato negli Stati Uniti,
e ha capito prima degli altri
la rilevanza della difesa delle foreste,
e delle risorse naturali americane.
L'ha capito, ma si danna l'anima
perché non riesce a convincere
l'amico Theodore Roosevelt,
Presidente degli Stati Uniti.
Le parole sono vane,
fino alla notte in cui
i due si incontrano,
in una notte improvvisata
di campeggio dentro la foresta.
Lo racconta Theodor Roosvelt:
quella notte, davanti al fuoco
insieme all'amico,
Roosevelt capisce col sentimento
quello che non era riuscito
a capire con l'intelligenza,
perché c'è una profonda differenza
tra sentire e capire.
Per anni l'amico gli aveva raccontato
la bontà di salvare le foreste,
ma lui non l'aveva sentito.
E lì è nato il più grande atto politico
di difesa delle risorse naturali
e delle foreste americane.
E oggi non avremmo i parchi nazionali,
oggi non avremmo
le grandi risorse naturali
che tutti godiamo negli Stati Uniti,
senza quella notte,
in campeggio con l'amico.
E 100 anni dopo un'altro uomo,
Francesco Bergoglio,
si troverà nella foresta,
in una notte improvvisata,
e sentirà, per la prima volta,
sentirà il grido dei popoli indigeni
e sentirà il grido
della Terra e della foresta.
Gli amici di Bergoglio dicono
che non era un ambientalista,
fino ad allora;
ma dopo quella notte,
Papa Bergoglio deciderà,
per la sua vita e per il mondo,
di dedicarsi alla causa ambientale.
Che cosa ci dicono queste storie?
Ci dicono che siamo, sempre,
molto meno ragionevoli
di quello che pensiamo;
e che proprio la ragione,
proprio come è fatta la nostra testa,
è il principale impedimento
a risolvere i problemi
che la nostra testa
ha realizzato nel mondo.
È singolare, ma "Homo Sapiens"
è esattamente l'impedimento.
E perché?
Perché conoscere una cosa,
conoscere i dati, sapere, avere capito
non significa avere l'attitudine.
a mettersi in gioco, a cambiare, ad agire.
Ma "Homo sapiens" -
e questo, naturalmente,
ce lo dicono da un secolo le neuroscienze,
ce lo dice la psicologia,
la psicologia comportamentale,
ce lo dicono le scienze
che si occupano dei comportamenti umani.
Ma "Homo Sapiens" ha tanti altri difetti,
che sono quelli
che ci riconosciamo dentro.
Siamo pigri, procrastiniamo le decisioni:
se appena appena
una decisione ci costa fatica,
la rimandiamo al giorno dopo.
Richard Thaler,
Premio Nobel per l'economia,
dice che siamo un po' stupidi;
abbiamo bisogno, ogni tanto,
di una spintarella, di quel "nudge "
che ci consente di fare
qualcosa che non faremmo.
Siamo pigri.
Siamo pigri, ma siamo anche conformisti.
Quanto ci piace adeguarci
a quello che fanno gli altri!
Quanto ci piacciono le norme sociali,
che ci fanno come da cappotto, da coperta,
che ci consente di fare
quello che noi vorremmo fare
ma senza la norma non lo faremo.
E così mettiamo la cintura di sicurezza
per andare in macchina,
perché ce lo impone la legge:
e così non fumiamo nei luoghi pubblici,
perché ce lo impone la legge,
e sappiamo che è giusto,
ma la nostra testa si rifiuta di farlo,
senza questa norma sociale.
E poi, l'ultima delle caratteristiche
del nostro cervello,
che è quella più interessante.
Siamo molto critici
coi comportamenti cattivi e nocivi;
e siamo molto, molto tolleranti,
il nostro cervello è tollerante
con le omissioni.
Che cosa vuol dire?
Che siamo critici con l'imprenditore
che venga colto a sversare
liquami inquinanti in un fiume.
Siamo molto critici, [con lui]:
ma siamo molto tolleranti
nei confronti di un Sindaco
di una grande città,
di un ministro
che non tuteli
la salute pubblica
migliorando la qualità
dell'aria o dell'acqua.
E questo dipende da come
è fatto il nostro cervello.
Siamo pigri, siamo conformisti,
amiamo fare quello che fanno gli altri;
e soprattutto, siamo benevoli
con le omissioni.
E allora qual è il punto?
Tutto quello che non facciamo,
tutti quegli infiniti comportamenti
che non mettiamo in atto,
e che sostanziano la crisi climatica,
perché noi siamo sempre portati a pensare
che la colpa sia di quello che facciamo,
quei pochi gesti che facciamo;
ma non contempliamo gli infiniti gesti
che noi non facciamo.
E allora, voi capite
che il problema siamo noi.
Il problema è come è fatta
la nostra testa.
Il problema è decidere
un radicale atto di auto-sovversione,
che vada contro la nostra
stessa natura umana.
Quest'auto-sovversione richiama
l'intelligenza collettiva -
non solo quella dei tecnici,
l'intelligenza di tutti noi -
verso il plasmare una città
che ispiri comportamenti ecologici.
Questo è più facile
di quello che noi ci immaginiamo,
perché dobbiamo lavorare
sugli spazi e sui tempi.
Pensate che in Svezia, a Växjö,
vengono pulite prima
le piste ciclabili, e poi le strade.
È un atto politico decidere che vengono
prima le piste ciclabili delle strade.
O in Inghilterra,
500 strade che vengono destinate
al gioco dei bambini con le famiglie,
quando le famiglie lo richiedono:
è un atto politico.
O addirittura Pontevedra, Spagna,
dove il sindaco ha deciso
che le auto in città
non ci entrano proprio.
E pensate che sono sopravvissuti:
anzi, i valori mobiliari
e i valori commerciali di quella città
sono cresciuti.
E poi possiamo agire sui consumi,
sulle abitudini quotidiane:
è facile!
Nella grande Svizzera,
che non è certo un paese del terzo mondo,
si sono riportate le lavatrici
al piano terreno,
perché così si riducono i consumi.
Amitav Ghosh, scrittore,
dice che la crisi climatica
è sostanzialmente una crisi culturale,
e dell'immaginazione.
La nostra incapacità collettiva
di pensare che le cose
possono essere diverse già da subito.
E allora, arrivo alla proposta e concludo.
La proposta è questa:
ogni città dovrebbe dotarsi
di un'équipe di "placemaker",
plasmatori di luoghi,
designer delle scelte,
architetti delle decisioni,
che ispirino emozioni nella popolazione,
capacità di azione,
esperienze a portata di mano per tutti,
possibilità che nelle città,
che sono il luogo delle moltitudini,
i comportamenti cambino.
Questa è la strada maestra.
In alternativa, c'è un piano B:
troverò il modo di passare una notte
in campeggio con Mario Draghi.
(Applausi)